hello everyone and welcome to what is
probably the most impressive game that
was played yesterday in the Chess
Masters F Grand Final between ala fua
and Magnus Carlson although it was
Magnus who had the the white pieces and
um uh well they they said that you know
up to for for for the first 40 moves the
players played at an engine like
Precision now I don't really like those
uh those uh terms because uh well let's
say 20 30 years from now you're and have
a really really strong engine and you
ask that engine how precise this game
was it will say it was maybe the the you
know playing strength of your everage
just playing Uncle uh but you know as
these are the the best we have nowadays
then they rate it very high I'm I'm I'm
only guessing but I'm pretty sure that's
how it's going to go so uh you know
while I don't like throwing around those
percentages while having a 99.1 or 99.3
percentage um of an engine like game it
means you've played very very well uh so
let's check it out and let's see what
happens at move 41 once all of these
moves are played so Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to G3 H we
have Pawn to D5 attacking the center
while white develops on the flank a very
hyper modern way to develop Knight F3 G6
and Bishop to G2 we have Bishop to G7 D4
and now Knight to F6 we have Pawn to C4
and pawn to C6 through a bit of a
different move order we've re the king's
Indian defense we have castles castles
and now transposing into the Neo
groomfield C3 D captures on C4 and now
Pawn to E4 and it's a pretty standard
stuff black will play B5 and B4 and
white wants to get E5 in but uh usually
you will sacrifice the pawn on D5
temporarily to prevent E5 and Knight to
D5 but you'll see what happens Pawn to
B5 we have Queen to E2 and now Pawn to
A5 preparing Pawn to B4 Rook to D1 by
Magnus and now Knight B to D7 and here
Pawn to D5 now like I've mentioned if
you play Pawn D5 first then you give
black this wonderful D5 square and uh
then you fix Black's Pawn structure and
it's nothing uh uh you know nothing
great for white so instead you sacrifice
a pawn temporarily and now after C
captures and D5 now you play Pawn to E5
of course you want the the the Knight to
move and to capture on D5 uh but uh B4
of course um ala will not move his
Knight and now e captures on F6 Knight
captures on F6 and now Knight to B5 and
uh it is now as of move 14 that we have
a completely new game now it's a pce
sacrifice but the Knight on B5 will not
be able to survive forever as you'll see
in the game uh also there is one game
where Knight to A4 was played it was
played last year between Max vam and
bascar Adan in the F Grand Swiss and
vardam won with Knight day4 with the
white pieces uh but also I want to show
you what happens if you go back with the
Knight let's say you try to keep your
peace and you just want to say okay I'm
going to the defend and I'm going to be
just going to be up an extra piece then
black has this E5 move and now the once
the pawns start marching forward it's
going to be impossible to defend this or
you capture on E5 then Rook E8 and it's
uh you know really really hard to to
find moves here for white like like
Bishop to F4 Bishop to G4 comes attacks
the queen and now you can play Bishop to
F3 but once everything gets traded off
let's say Knight to D7 you put more
pressure on the on the E file Bishop
captures Knight captures on E5 Bishop
captures Bishop captures The Rook now
x-raying the White Queen so you have to
move it Queen to F6 putting pressure on
B2 and this Knight really I mean it's an
extra piece but uh uh it really is an
extra piece like it's it's uh you know
should be gone let's say Bishop captures
uh you have I mean three two pass pawns
one more will probably be created The
Rook is coming down the board uh it's uh
I mean uh not right at the moment
because the bishop is on G4 but um it's
an overwhelming position to defend so
instead after Knight captures on F6
Knight to B5 is played and okay let's
see how ala deals with this bishop D7 he
attacks magnus's Knight Pawn to A4
defends the Knight and he captures
captures captures and now Pawn to E6
defends the D5 pawn and he now has this
beautiful Pawn chain consisting of eight
pawns where Magnus has only Five Pawns
so three pawns for the piece also the B
pawns are doubled so you know it's a
it's definitely a trade-off to say the
least we have to D4 Magnus wants to go
to C6 to eliminate the B4 Pawn if alza
starts advancing too early and he does
he plays Pawn to A4 which is uh in fact
very strong Knight to C6 attacks the
queen queen to B6 Knight captures Queen
captures and now Bishop to D2 so okay
it's a little bit easier to breathe
you've eliminated one of these pawns and
you will put a bishop on C3 to counter
Al is a strong dragon on G7 uh Knight to
D7 threatening Bishop captures on B2 and
Bishop to C3 and okay the bishop is very
strong here but it is a bit overworked
uh you know defending the the Knight
here and the pawn on B2 uh so here
Knights to C5 and now Pawn to H4 Magnus
goes um after the the black king and
while you could move the Knight to C2 to
try and keep the Knight again like I
said like captures uh the Bishop B Bish
B captures bishop and queen B2 uh the a
PA marches forward the Knight comes to
B3 or D3 it's just impossible to defend
this with white uh so instead after
Knight to C5 Pawn to H4 and now Knight
to B3 uh and Bishop captures on G7 you
could also play Rook to A2 but uh it's
impossible to actually capture on A1 so
that's why Bishop captures on G7 first
and the reason is it's impossible is
that because after you capture you bring
the bishop back you defend the Knight
and the Knight is still hanging and if
you try to save the Knight Queen E5 and
it's game over there's no way to defend
if you play you can't even play D4
because the queen on B5 would hang so if
F6 you're going to Capt AP here and if
King G7 Rook captures on D5 attacks the
queen Rook to D7 and it's a you know a
very short King hunt that will and
successfully so after Bishop captures
and G7 King captures and G7 and now
Queen to E5 with check again Knight C2
you could try and save the Knight but um
uh it's not going to really work you're
going to take the rook and once Rook
captures Queen captures on B2 and now
you have to deal with all of these extra
you know past pawns so instead Queen to
E check right away uh we have Pawn to F6
defending and now Queen captures on E6
and finally uh ala eliminates the extra
piece so Queen captures on B4 Rook
captures on D5 now Magnus going for the
king hunt and now Rook to A7 again very
very important move uh because if you
capture The Rook here now then comes
Rook D7 check and after King to h8 all
the other moves are you know if if you
go here then it's just a very brief King
hunt and if you go here then Bishop
captures on A8 and it's a terrible
position for black if you capture then
just Queen F7 it's impossible to defend
and if you try to push let's say you
create a pass pawn and you know try to
do something then Bishop to D5 and after
C3 Rook F7 a threatening Queen captures
on F6 and once you trade here now you're
threatening Checkmate here and you're
either getting checkmated here or you
defend that Checkmate and then it's
Checkmate via the F6 Square the bishop
covers G7 so that's why Knight captures
on A1 is impossible Rook to A7 was
played again after absolutely uh the the
the strongest engine move Rook 8 to D1
now preparing Rook D7 check and Rook to
E7 attacking the queen but still Rook D7
Rook F to F7 putting pressure on The
Rook Here and Now Rook captures on E7 we
have Rook captures on E7 the queen of
course defending the Rook uh and Rook to
D7 again forcing the trade here Rook
captures Queen captures with check King
H6 and Bishop to D5 now now this is a uh
a good idea especially with uh well not
a little time on the clock they're both
still above 3 minutes on the clock but
it's a it's an attempt at uh at a win uh
if if you didn't want to do that You'
probably go for something like Queen to
d8 and try to harass the black king from
behind but he played Bishop to D5 the
idea being that uh this Pawn covers the
G5 square and if you can get your Bishop
let's say here then Queen to H7 is
Checkmate also you're putting pressure
on this diagonal which could be very
relevant but Ala plays Queen to E1 with
check and after King to G2 Knight to D2
this Knight to d2 move uh is the only
way for him to play but it is the one
that stops the nasty idea of just
getting checkmated because if you go for
it now then it's just Queen to F1 check
King H2 and Knight to F3 Checkmate so
Magnus has to figure out how to defend
this and he does with the only move
Queen to A7 defends the pawn on F2 and
now Queen to E5 uh trying to bait Magnus
to go for Queen to E3 check but Queen to
E3 check uh would lose him the game yes
it's a very nice nice Queen trade but
after everything gets traded off look at
this A3 and now you don't have a you
don't have a way of dealing with this
because if B captures you're going to
play a pawn to C3 and now the Knight
covers both B3 and E4 the bishop cannot
use those squares to defend C2 and once
the pawn touches C2 of course C1 is a
dark Square the light Square Bishop is
absolutely useless there so that's why
Queen to C5 is played and now we have
King to G7 Magnus goes back uh we have
Queen to A5 now attacking the Knight and
pawn to A3 a very nice sacrifice because
if you capture the Knight here then
comes a captures on B2 with the thread
of B1 Queen and after Queen to D1
stopping that you can just give up the
queen uh well your newly promoted Queen
and after let's say queen captures on D5
with check King G1 C3 and now the pawn
uh will of course win you the game H you
can play it something like Queen to E1
uh but it doesn't matter Queen to C6 you
you want to push the pawn if you give
one check the king is very safe on G8
Queen to d8 with check you're going to
play King to F7 now no more checks and
you have to go back now C2 Queen to C1
and queen to E4 you will go after the D1
check to trade off Queens if you know
there's nothing to do here uh even if
you could somehow get the king to F1
then Queen to H1 would would pick up the
queen so you know it's useless uh but
after A3 B captures on A3 was played and
now Pawn to C3 uh Queen to A7 with a
nice check King to H six and now Queen
to C uh sorry and now Queen to C5 uh But
Here Comes Pawn to C2 of course you
cannot capture it the the bishop would
hang while defending the Knight and here
we have Queen to f8 with check King to
H5 reaching move 40 and up until this
point both of them uh have played with
engine like Precision but now there is
only one move that allows Magnus to
continue the game so feel free to pause
the video for the first time and try to
find the only move that doesn't lose the
game for Magnus while give you a couple
of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this uh brilliant idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to G4 with check and the
reason for this is that it doesn't
matter which Pawn you capture if you
capture the pawn on H4 uh then it's
Queen to H6 with check and uh once the
king moves you just pick up the Knight
you you pick up the Knight you defend
the bishop and you control the queening
square and if after G4 check the king
captures on G4 then it's the other way
around Queen to B4 check again connects
with the Knight king or if Queen to F4
blocking check trying to trade off
queens and then promote the C Pawn you
play F3 with check and now once the king
moves to H5 now he will pick up the
queen on F4 and black will get another
queen into the game but this will be a
repetition either by uh Queen F4 check
and now you go here and it's a
repetition or King to G7 and then okay
the game continues but still uh uh uh uh
objectively a draw however after this um
King to H5 move Magnus did not find Pawn
to G4 he was down to 30 seconds on the
clock ala was below 20 seconds on the
clock H but Magnus played Queen to F7 he
wanted to just play Queen captures on H7
but now alza has a winning idea so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for alza while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
punishing the first non-engine move of
the game and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Pawn H6 and
now you see the horror of what you have
done now G4 check doesn't do anything
the queen is no longer on f8 to be able
to come to H6 now G4 King captures on H4
and there's no continuation here there's
absolutely nothing you can do here so
instead after this H6 move uh Queen to
D7 was played by Magnus but also he lost
on time here uh but it doesn't matter
even if he didn't lose on time there
there is no move yeah Magnus actually
played the the top the top engine move
the engine gives in this losing position
but still uh there's nothing to be done
you just bring a Queen into the game and
this one check King captures on H4
there's no continuation here all of the
uh I mean the king is on a dark Square
the Queen the bishop nothing can touch
the black king on H4 and there's just no
good way to continue uh black has two
queens it's going to be a it's going to
be a very quick
Checkmate uh so yeah brilliant stuff by
both of them uh not easy to play you
know a rapid chess with uh with u you
know such such engine like Precision
even though okay they both really knew
the opening well and of course they know
the ins and outs how to you know you
know play the position after the opening
but it's still you know there were there
was so much to calculate here and it's
just incredibly impressive that they
were able to do so but yeah alza took
Magnus down in the first one he took him
down in the second one again Magnus got
a bad position uh and uh I I think he
also almost almost either lost on time
or you know had a really bad position so
he resigned uh then he won the third
game and then uh agreed to draw in the
forth in the previous video I I
accidentally misinformed you saying that
alza won the first two games and then
Magnus drew the third one uh but it was
actually that uh Magnus won the third
one and the fourth game ended in a draw
uh but yeah brilliant stuff by both of
them I hope you enjoyed it and hope you
were able to solve both of these um uh
ideas uh so yeah really hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Jeremy anos
Carl Weinberg rajish churi Brian Stone
and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day